>>> HAPPY WEEK NINE, EVERYBODY.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE VR
BETTING QUAD LIVE IN THE BEACHER
REPORT APP PRESENTED BY DRINKS.
FOR THE FIRST TIME THIS SEASON,
HE IS IN STUDIO WITH ME AT
BLEACHER REPORT NEW YORK CITY.
GREG, THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE
COMING OFF THE BIG FIGHT NIGHT.
HOW YOU FEELING?
>> FEELING GOOD.
WE WON SOME MONEY YESTERDAY.
LOST A LITTLE BIT BUT GOT IT
BACK.
FEELING GOOD ABOUT THAT.
I WANT TO FEEL EVEN BETTER.
I CAN DO THAT BY GIVING AWAY
HOOD DYIES TO THE PEOPLE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
IT SAYS COOPER KUPP, PATTERSON
EQUALS THE PARLAY.
THE LEGENDS ARE TOGETHER IN
PERSON
PERSON.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> NORTHEAST L.A. GAVE US A
GIFT.
YOU WERE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOO
HOODIE.
>> HE DOESN'T COME EMPTY HANDED.
HE PACKS THAT SUITCASE, HOODIES
GALORE.
>> YES, SIR.
>> ON FRIDAY WE ASKED YOU, WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE LOCKS OF
THE WEEK OF WHO'S GETTING INTO
THE END ZONE.
EZEKIEL ELLIOTT AT THE TOP,
NAJEE HARRIS, SUPERSTAR ROOKIE.
BIGGS RETURNS TO THE FIELD.
THOSE ARE NO SURPRISES.
SCOTT AND SCHULTZ AT THE BOTTOM
AND TRAVIS KELCE AS WELL.
HE HAS NOT GOTTEN IN THE END
ZONE THE LAST THREE WEEKS,
DISAPPOINTING US A BIT.
WE'RE EXCITED.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GIVE AWAY.
>> EVERYBODY AT HOME, WE ARE
GIVING AWAY TWO NFL JERSEY GIFT
CARDS.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY ONE TO THE
WINNER OF THE TOURNAMENT AND ONE
TO A LUCKY COMMENTER LIKE
YOURSELF.
STAY TUNED, STAY TAPPED IN.
I NEED GIFTS.
I NEED EMOJIS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, I NEED WINNERS
ONLY.
PLEASE TYPE THAT OUT IN THE
COMMENTS.
I AM GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
>> WE HAVE NOW CASHED IN THE
SQUAD RIDE THE LAST THREE WEEKS.
I THINK TODAY WE'RE FEELING REAL
GOOD.
LET'S DO IT AGAIN.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU.
THE PEOPLE ARE BRINGING IT.
THE LAST ONE STANDING, SQUAD
RIDE LEADER, THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING, NFL JERSEY, WE'RE GOING
TO FOLLOW THAT PERSON, TRAIL THE
BET AND MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
IT'S TIME FOR ROUND ONE.
THE FIRST PITCH OF THE OBERMEYE
>> ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE?
IS IT GOING TO BE THIS LEAGUE?
AND IT IS.
SCHULTZ ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
SCORER.
>> SCHULTZ MAKING HIS WAY INTO
CONTENTION HERE.
THAT IS SOME OF THE BIG MONEY
WE'VE HAD ON THE SHOW, PLUS 190.
IT'S TIME FOR THE FIRST MATCHUP
OR SECOND PITCH.
>> WE HAVE ATLAS HERE.
HE'S GOING TO PICK OUR ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORER OF THE WEEK.
WE'VE GOT EZEKIEL ELLIOTT AND
COOK WE'LL SEE WHICH ONE HE
PICKS UP.
READY, ATLAS?
HE'S A LITTLE INDECISIVE HERE.
ATLAS, WHICH ONE?
HE'S GOT THE BLUE BALL!
THE BLUE BALL HERE, WHICH ATLAS
JUST STOLE AGAIN HAS ZEKE.
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORER OF THE
WEEK.
>> ATLAS COMING IN CLUTCH WITH
THE EZEKIEL ELLIOTT PICK AT
MINUS 150.
NOT THAT CRAZY.
THEY HAVE THE BRONCOS ON TAP
TODAY.
>> I KNOW HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
THAT PLUS MONEY.
>> YOU KNOW I LOVE THAT PLUS
MONEY.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND LET ME KNOW IF YOU
ARE RIDING WITH THE LEGEND.
ARE WE GOING WITH DALTON SCHULTZ
AND EZEKIEL ELLIOTT.
WEEK TWO, WE DIDN'T KNOW WHO
DALTON SCHULTZ WAS.
I LIKE THE ODDS AT PLUS 190, BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF WEAPONS IN THAT
COWBOYS OFFENSE.
SPEAKING OF WEAPONS, EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT IS A GOOD WEAPON.
I THINK I WANT TO LEAN WITH HIM.
>> I KNOW WHAT YOU COULD DO WITH
THESE ODDS.
IF WE COULD GET THAT MINUS 150
TO EVEN MONEY, I FEEL GOOD ABOUT
ZEKE GETTING INTO THE END ZONE
THIS WEEK.
CEEDEE LAMB IS GOING TO PLAY.
HE COMES THROUGH IN THE CLUTCH
ALL THE TIME FOR THEM.
I'M RIDING WITH ATLAS.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT.
LET'S LET THE iPAD DECIDE
MATCHUP NUMBER ONE.
>> I GOT DANIEL GUTTMAN WITH THE
ZEKE GIFT.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
JOHNNY, DO NOT BE ALARMED,
BROTHER.
WE HERE AT THE SQUAD RIDE CAN
BOOST THESE ODDS FOR YOU.
DO NOT BE ALARMED BY THE JUICE.
JOHNNY77, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH THE HOODIE.
I HAVE RENALD RAY.
SHO
SHOUTOUT TO EVERYONE I
MENTIONED, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE
>> THE PEOPLE ARE RIDING WITH
ZEKE, THEY'RE RIDING WITH ATLAS.
THAT MEANS GOLDBERG MOVES TO
ROUND NUMBER TWO.
TWO CHALLENGERS REMAINING.
THE NEXT PITCH COMES FROM JOHN
COONEY.
WHO ARE YOU RIDING WITH HERE IN
WEEK NUMBER NINE?
♪
>> BOSTON'S GOT PLUS 140 ANY
TIME TOUCHDOWNS.
>> WE GOT THE PROP WHEEL LEGEND.
YOU KNOW WE GOT THE FETCH
LEGEND.
WHEEL GOING WITH BOSTON SCOTT,
WHO QUIETLY HAS THREE TOUCHDOWNS
IN HIS LAST TWO GAMES.
HE'S BEEN HOT.
>> HE'S BEEN HOT.
>> YOU KNOW HOW WE USUALLY FEEL
ABOUT THAT.
THAT USUALLY SCARES US AWAY.
I KNOW YOU FEEL A CERTAIN WAY
ABOUT THE MESSY PHILLY
BACKFIELD.
>> YES, I DO.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO TELL ME HOW
YOU GUYS FEEL ABOUT BOSTON SCOTT
VERSUS EZEKIEL ELLIOTT.
WHO DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD RIDE
WITH?
THAT BACKFIELD IN PHILADELPHIA,
THEY HAVE THREE RUNNING BACKS.
>> BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A MAIN
ONE.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
I SAW JORDAN ALBERT SCORE A
COUPLE TOUCHDOWNS LAST WEEK.
I KNOW THAT ZEKE IS THE BACK IN
DALLAS.
>> HE'S THE WORKHORSE GUY.
HE'S GOT THAT $100 MILLION
CONTRACT AT THIS POINT.
YOU KNOW HE'S GETTING THE BALL.
I LOVE TONY POLLARD AS WELL.
BUT THE ODDS ARE VERY DIFFERENT
FOR A REASON.
ZEKE SHOULD FIND HIS WAY INTO
THE END ZONE TODAY.
I DO LOVE THE PROP WHEEL VIDEO.
KEEP BRINGING IT.
WE'VE BEEN GUIDING THE SQUAD
EACH WEEK SINCE THE COOPER
KUPP --
>> WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO LEAD YOU
ALL THE WAY.
>> ARE THEY STAYING WITH ATLAS
AND ZEKE OR BOSTON SCOTT?
>> I'M IN THE HANDY DANDY iPAD.
HE HAS THE ZEKE GIFT OF JUMPING
OVER A DEFENDER.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
T GIBSON SAYS GERMAN SHEPHERDS
KNOW BEST.
ANY TIME ELLIOT TOUCHDOWN ALL
DAY.
THAT IS HOW YOU GET A HOODIE.
I GOT GARZA WHO SAYS Z.
>> ZEKE GOT ROUND ONE, GOT ROUND
TWO.
CAN HE PULL OFF THE UNDEFEATED
STRETCH HERE?
I WANT TO SEE GREG GET THAT TO
AT LEAST EVEN MONEY.
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD TIME.
FINAL ROUND.
WINNER TAKES HOME SQUAD RIDE
TITLE, WINNER TAKES HOME NFL
JERSEY.
HOPEFULLY WINNER GETS US WEEK
NUMBER FOUR IN A ROW OF THE
SQUAD RIDE CASHING OUT.
CHRIS, ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE
TO UNSEE ATLAS?
>> WE HAVE ALVIN KAMARA, WE GOT
ZEKE, WE GOT CHELSEA.
WHO'S SCORING THIS WEEKEND?
UH-OH.
IT'S KELSECE.
HE'S SCORING THIS WEEKEND.
>> TRAVIS KELCE HAS BEEN ICE
COLD LATELY.
HE HASN'T SCORED IN HIS LAST
THREE GAMES.
HE'S DUE.
>> HE'S DUE.
>> KIND OF IRONIC, WE GOT A DOG
AGAINST A ROOMBA.
FETCH LEGEND, ROOMBA LEGEND,
KELCE, ZEKE.
THESE ARE ALL RELIABLE THINGS.
>> YES.
>> I'M STILL GOING WITH ZEKE.
IS THIS GOING TO SWAY YOU?
IS THIS GOING TO SWAY THEM?
>> CONNOR, YOU KNOW WHEN THESE
TOUGH DECISIONS COME, I USUALLY
LEAN ON THE PEOPLE.
GUESS WHAT I'M GOING TO DO IN
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE?
I'M GOING TO LEAN ON THE PEOPLE
AND IN THE COMMENTS YOU GUYS LET
ME KNOW ARE WE RIDING WITH
TRAVIS KELCE OR EZEKIEL ELLIOTT.
I GOT WHEEZY 804 WHO ALSO SAYS
TRAVIS KELCE WITH A GIFT CARD.
I SEE ZEKE RED SOX IN FIVE,
ZEKE.
SHO
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
I ALSO SEE BLAKE STEAMEN.
EASY MONEY WINNERS.
IT'S 2-2.
THE NEXT ONE WINNER TAKES ALL.
SCROLLING.
BAM.
ASHLEY GUERRERO.
ZEKE.
WE EVEN SAID IT, EZEKIEL ELLIOTT
IS WINNING THE SQUAD RIDE.
CAN WE PLEASE PULL UP THE
GRAPHICS
>> WHAT CAN WE DO WITH THIS?
>> DO NOT BE ALARMED IT'S MINUS
150, BECAUSE THE MANIGIC IS GOI
TO HAPPEN.
NOW IT'S PLUS 100.
SHOUTOUT TO OUR PEOPLE AT
DRAFTKINGS FOR DOING THIS.
>> THE PEOPLE TRAILED US, THEY
TRAILED ATLAS.
I'M READY FOR WEEK NUMBER FOUR
IN A ROW OF A WIN.
WE ARE NOT DONE.
THE MAN IS HERE.
HE'S STILL GOT PLENTY OF
HOODIES.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE COMMUNITY
COMMENT CONTEST.
WE'RE HALFWAY THROUGH THE
SEASON.
WE'VE GOT TO ASK YOU THE
QUESTION OF ALL QUESTIONS.
WHO'S GOING TO WIN THIS MVP?
IT'S TIME TO CHECK IN.
HALFWAY THROUGH, YOU GOT AN IDEA
WHAT QUARTERBACK'S ON FIRE.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY EVEN.
LOOK AT THIS GROUP RIGHT HERE.
JOSH ALLEN AT THE TOP, KIND OF A
CLEAR FAVORITE.
THAT'S A BIG DISPARITY BETWEEN
ODDS.
STAFFORD REJUVENATED WITH SEAN
McVAY AND THE RAMS.
HE'S BEEN GREAT.
TOM BRADY HAS PRETTY MUCH BEEN
TOM BRADY.
KYLER MURRAY IS A STAR,
ESPECIALLY IN THE FANTASY WORLD.
ARRARON RODGERS, I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE THROWING
MVP MONEY ON HIM.
NO DAK PRESCOTT ON THIS LIST
>> SURPRISING.
>> HE'S MISSED ONE GAME BUT HE'S
BEEN GREAT.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE SAYING.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT COMMENTS YOU
WANT TO SHOW.
>> LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
I'M IN NEW YORK.
IT'S COLD HERE.
I SEE BIG MIKE 13 SAYS ALLEN
DESERVES MVP.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO TELL ME WHICH
COMMENT I'M GOING TO READ, WHICH
COMMENT YOU GUYS LIKE BETTER.
LET'S GET INTO IT, MAN.
STARTING OFF WITH SAUCE 90, I
GOT THE G.O.A.T., TOM BRADY
WINNING THAT I GUESS MVP.
IT GOES EMOJI EMOJI CHAMPIONSHIP
EMOJI.
CONNOR, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS TAKE?
>> HE'S DONE IT THREE TIMES
ALREADY, RIGHT?
HE'S WON THE MVP THREE TIMES
ALREADY.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY THE HOUSEHOLD
NAME OF THE NFL.
THE ONE THING THAT SCARES ME
BESIDES THE FACT HE'S GOT GOOD
HEALTHY COMPETITION ON THAT
BOARD.
I BELIEVE IN BRAIDY FATIGUE FOR
THE VOTING.
IF HE'S NOT LEAPS AND BOUNDS
BETTER THAN ALL THOSE GUYS,
THEY'VE GIVE IT TO SOMEONE ELSE.
NOT A VZCRAZY COMMENT, BUT I'M
CURIOUS WHAT THE SECOND COMMENT
HAS TO SAY.
>> IN WHAT WORLD HAS JOSH ALLEN
PLAYED BETTER THAN DAK AND
STAFFORD?
WHAT A JOKE.
>> THE DAK HATE OR THE LACK OF
DAK LOVE, I SHOULD SAY, I'M WITH
YOU ON THAT.
DAK, HE'S MISSED THE GAME.
THIS IS A NUMBERS GAME IN THE
MVP RACE.
HE'S GOING TO BE BEHIND FOR NOW
BUT I THINK HE'S BEEN THE BEST
QUARTERBACK IN THE NFL WHEN HE'S
ON THE FIELD.
QUITE FRANKLY, THE MVP ISN'T
NECESSARILY THE BEST QUARTERBACK
IN THE NFL ALL THE TIME.
THE MVP CAN BASICALLY BE A
NUMBERS GAME, A TEAM THAT'S
WINNING.
YOU LOOK AT JOSH ALLEN AND THE
BILLS.
THEY'RE GOING TO RUN THROUGH
THAT DIVISION, NO DOUBT ABOUT
THAT.
I LIKE THE COMMENT, I TOTALLY
GET IT.
I'M WITH YOU ON THE DAK LOVE.
THE MVP RACE IS GOING TO BE
COMPLICATED.
>> YES, SIR.
I TOLD YOU GUYS ABOUT JOSH ALLEN
EARLY ON.
HE'S THE FAVORITE NOW.
>> HE GETS THOSE RUSHING
TOUCHDOWNS.
>> HE DOES.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS SEEING WHO
ARE WE CHOOSING.
BLAKE STEAMEN SAYS COOPER KUPP.
AUSTIN 981 HAS KYLER MURRAY.
EVERYBODY I MENTIONED WALKS AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
I LIKE SAUCE 90'S COMMENT.
HE'S GOING TO WIN THE CONTEST.
SAUCE 90 IS ALSO WALKING AWAY
WITH A SHOUTOUT.
>> WE GOT TO GET HIGH AGAIN.
WE STARTED OUT A LOT COLD, WE
GOT REALLY HOT.
IT'S BEEN TOUGH THIS TIME OF
YEAR.
WE'RE KIND OF TEAMING UP ON THIS
ONE.
BEFORE WE GIVE THAT AWAY, TELL
THE PEOPLE WHAT WE NEED.
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME
KNOW.
I NEED A LOT OF SUNSETS IN THE
COMMENTS.
GO TO YOUR PHONE, GO TO THE
EMOJI SECTION, CLICK A SUNSET
AND FILL THOSE COMMENTS UP WITH
SUNSETS.
WE'RE ON THE SAME TEAM HERE.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE ARE
RIDING WITH.
>> THE NAME YOU GOT TO KNOW HERE
IS ALVIN KAMARA.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE WATCHING THAT
SAINTS GAME.
I THINK HE GETS IN THE END ZONE
TWICE TODAY.
SEAN PAYTON ALWAYS BRINGS A
LITTLE EXTRA JUICE AGAINST THE
FALC
FALCONS.
THE FALCONS HAVE GIVEN UP AT
LEAST EIGHT TOUCHDOWNS TO
RUNNING BACKS THIS YEAR.
WE KNOW HE CAN DO IT ON THROUGHE
AIR AND ON THE GROUND.
RELY ON ALVIN KAMARA.
I THINK YOU GOT A LITTLE BIT OF
THE SAME VIBES RIGHT NOW.
>> CONNOR, WE HAVE SUNSETS IN
THE COMMENTS.
SHUTOUT TO EVERYBODY.
LET ME GIVE AWAY A HOODIE.
I GOT RILEY.
THANK YOU FOR THE SUNSETS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I WANT TO GO ALVIN KAMARA FIRST
TOUCHDOWN SCORER.
HAVE THE BACKUP QUARTERBACK IN
FACING THE ATLANTA FALCONS'
DEFENSE.
TREVOR SIMEON I THINK IS
STARTING.
A LOT OF CHECKDOWNS TO AK.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH IT, MAN.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET A
CHECKDOWN.
ALVIN KAMARA IS GOING TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN AND SCORE AGAIN IN THE
SECOND OR THIRD QUARTER.
>> PLUS 380 ON THE DOUBLE
TOUCH
TOUCHDOWNS.
HE IS HEALTHY.
SIMEON WAS ABLE TO KEEP THE
CHACHA
CHAINS MOVING LAST WEEK.
IT'S A GOOD SIGN.
IF YOU WANT TO TRAIL, YOU'RE
TRAILING THE AL VENN VIN KAMARA.
>> A LOT OF SUNSETS ARE IN THE
COMMENTS.
THERE IT IS.
YOU GUYS CAN SEE MY SCREEN.
KEEP THE SUNSETS FLOWING,
PLEASE, BECAUSE WE NEED GOOD
VIBES.
LET ME GIVE AWAY THIS JERSEY,
CONNOR.
YOUNG GRAVY 56.
YOU SEE THE SUNSETTING THERE.
IT'S SUCH A BEAUTIFUL SIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
THAT'S LOVE, MAN.
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY ONE MORE
HOODIE.
MARVIN BAGELS YOU'RE IN THE
PERFECT SPOT.
CONNOR.
>> IT HAS BEEN FUN, MAN.
MY GUY'S GOT TO GET HOME.
HE'S BEEN ON THE ROADWAY TOO
LONG.
HE HASN'T GOTTEN TO SLEEP.
I GOT TO GET HOME AS WELL.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR WEST AGERS,
EVERYONE.
HAVE NO FEAR, YOU'RE GETTING
THAT GEAR.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
COMMENTED.
WE ALWAYS APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENT STREAM.
SHOUTOUT TO ATLAS, THE FETCH
LEGEND MAKING MONEY FOR US
TODAY.
>> IT'S USUALLY WHEN I'M NOT
HOME, BUT CONNOR, HOLD ON.
I GOT TO GET BACK INTO THE
COMMENTS BECAUSE I'M IN NEW YORK
AND I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES
BECAUSE WHY NOT.
WE GOT PACKER NATION 420 GIVING
US THE SUNSETS.
ENDERMAN IS BACK.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU FOR THE SUNSET
VIBES.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
T GIBSON 28, LET'S GO.
CONNOR, THAT'S IT.
>> ALL GOOD THINGS MUST COME TO
AN END.
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF FUN TODAY.
ENJOY YOUR FOOTBALL SUNDAY.
FOLLOW THE SQUAD.
FOR THE LAST THREE WEEKS THE
TOUCHDOWN SCORING IS HAPPENING.
THIS WEEK YOU KNOW THE DEAL.
WE'RE WATCHING ZEKE ELLIOTT AND
ALVIN KAMARA.
MY NAME IS CONNOR ROGERS.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK, SAME TIME,
SAME PLACE.
>> PEACE.
♪